the next award is for film editing one
of the presenters is a most talented and
lovely actress Jane Seymour the other
presenter makes the world a much happier
place to be and I am glad he is living
in it
Jane Seymour and Richard Pryor
film editors the people who put it all
together when you make a movie and the
director says that's a wrap at the end
of the day's shooting the film is rushed
to the lab for processing then it comes
back to the editors that's right and
they look at it first thing in the
morning
that explains why most film editors are
grouchy all day long there go all my
future close-ups
and here are the nominations for best
achievement in film editing authorship
David blew it for the competition
and V coats for the elephant man
jerry handling the same
now the school maker for Raging Bull
No how do you open it
okay right and the winner is Thelma
Schoonmaker
thank you very much I'm very proud to
have this I want to thank first of all
Marty Scorsese he edited this film with
me every minute of the time I want to
thank him particularly for his brilliant
direction and Robert De Niro for his
incredible performance which gave me
gold to work with pure gold of course
all the members of my staff and the W
crew particularly my first assistants on
your Polanski who worked so incredibly
hard on the film Frank Warner for his
wonderful sound effects editing job and
lastly or when Winkler and Robert
charred off for their tremendous support
during the making of the film thank you